on the streets of myanmar
this is now one of the most powerful
weapons
people have
done
but this was really the first time that
we were seeing a brutal crackdown
live streamed from the country the
military which sees
power knows this it's been shutting off
the internet
and trying to stop people filming we're
watching it
we're seeing it and the courageous
people in myanmar
are giving us a front row seat for the
horror that is
their their daily life
these tactics are working fewer streams
are now coming out of the country
while the numbers dying rapidly rises
on one day alone at least 114
people were killed
sky news has been tracking live streams
coming out of myanmar
we're going to show you why people are
continuing to risk their lives to film
on their phones
how they could play a key part in
gaining justice
in the future for the country
sister anne rose a new tong caught the
world's attention when she knelt in
front of police and
begged them to stop shooting protesters
a live stream was recorded on the same
day and place where sister anne rosa
made her plea
it shows exactly what she was trying to
prevent
brutal violence and vicious injuries
it's 12 36 on monday the 8th of march
in my gina it's the capital city
of the northern state of caching
a now familiar scene is underway
a clash between protesters and security
forces
local man corsail le tour is one of many
filming the street battle by live
streaming he makes it easy to verify
the time and date of the video
that can be cross-referenced with the
duration of the video
to pinpoint exactly when moments in the
stream are happening
and we can verify who has filmed it
the protesters are locked in a clash
with military and police
we can see many are filming using their
phones
gunfire starts we know from the stream
this happens at 12 39
20 seconds later we glimpse a line of
armed police
there's a standoff many live streams are
coming out from the area
with one catching core moving behind a
car
people begin to flee call runs
but is determined to keep filming
a woman has been shot her clothing
allows us to spot her again
later in the stream her arm has been
torn apart
cor and the others move off the main
road into a residential area at 12
41 pm seconds later we see a
second injury a man's skull
has been cracked open we hear him cough
and see people washing their faces
indicating they're suffering the effects
of tear gas
course stops to show us the extent of
the man's injuries
the wounds suggest he's been shot with
live ammunition
from a semi-automatic rifle
a few minutes later we see a third badly
injured person
he's unconscious blood pulls under his
head
at 12 47 p.m corsair la tour
heads towards a nearby building that
houses a medical clinic
here we see a fourth injured person
being tended to on a chair
now inside course shows us how nuns are
working alongside
medics and other protesters to tend to
the wounded
in the malign clinic we can see sister
anne rosa she's helping to treat
three of the injured people we saw
earlier
all of whom we can spot from their
clothing
local news reports say two died
following the protest that day
and seven people were badly wounded
caused stream shows us one was taken
away in an
ambulance while others received cpr
32 minutes after it began his live
stream
ends with a casing from a bullet
the shape of the casing indicates it was
used in a rifle
what we've seen from that incident and
incidents like it is uh
just the situation where you have
unarmed people protesting
as that is their right to freedom of
expression freedom of assembly
and then being gunned down streets by
security forces using live ammunition
there have been hundreds of streams
coming out of myanmar
often from big cities like yangon
mandalay and mondra
and these streams are being gathered as
evidence
it's it's clear what's going on i mean
it's it's clear before
before our very eyes we can we can see
what's what's happening yes live
streaming is is more potent
for example i think there's just clear
evidence of crimes against humanity
but between internet and data blackouts
and lack of digital access in rural
areas
we're still not seeing the full picture
initially there was a truly overwhelming
volume of live streams coming out but
that's
slow to a real trickle there are hardly
any live streams now
and that's because of the mobile
internet shutdown
it's getting to the point where i'm
starting to be concerned
more about what we're not seeing as
opposed to what we are